welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and if you've been
following our breakdowns of the MCU
movies then you'll know there's a lot of
incredible shots in them that reappear
throughout the franchise to signify
certain elements and aspects throughout
this video we'll be breaking down the
best parallels in the infinity saga
which will hopefully help you to
appreciate the movies more obviously
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't had a chance to watch all of
the films from Ironman too far from home
then I highly recommend that you turn
off now make sure you subscribe to the
channel for Marvel videos every week and
please drop a thumbs up if you enjoy the
breakdown without the way thank you for
clicking this and let's get into our
breakdown of the best MCU parallels okay
so the first big one happens in 2008
sighing man and it doesn't come full
circle until infinity war ten years
later in the original movie tony is
double-crossed by his good friend
Obadiah Stane who decides that the arc
reactor being used as a weapon is more
important than the character's life he
paralyzes Tony and takes the reactor
from his chest which leaves him at
death's door now mirroring this an
infinity war Dan ah stabs Tony with his
own blade which to critically injures
the character Obadiah respectfully says
his goodbyes to Tony and this is
mirrored in Thanos who does the same
thing in both moments Tony's life is
saved by someone else as firstly an Iron
Man dummy hands him his arc reactor and
in infinity war dr. strange hands over
the time stone to Thanos
we saw everything coming full circle
throughout these scenes with Tony going
on to fight his first big bad in stain
and then the last one that he would
fight which was of course Thanos here it
is sort of setting up his first and
final big bowels it sort of shows the
beginning and the end and this is an
incredible detail that brings everything
full circle similarly the first and last
time that we see the Iron Man helmet are
both shot in similar ways
when Tony makes the Mach 1 in the cave
he places the face plate down and this
shot is later reused in Avengers end
game to deliver his parting message to
his family it really is a brilliant use
of repetition and it shows how much
Marvel pay attention to the
cinematographer
dan ass is also a sort of opposite to
Tony as Tony is willing to sacrifice
himself that create a better universe
for his daughter
whereas Stannis is willing to sacrifice
his daughter to make a better universe
for himself when Tony dies his friends
and family namely pepper all stand
around him and say their goodbyes giving
them the closure as well as Tony who
passes away safe in the knowledge that
things are going to be alright the angle
of this shot has been purposely picked
to call back to the Baths moment in
civil war in which Tony says goodbye to
his parents
we know that the character and never got
the chance to do this in real life and
thus he used the hologram technology as
a sort of therapy to do it he always
wished that he had the opportunity to
properly say goodbye to his parents but
here the Avengers in Pepper actually get
the chance to which is sort of a
bittersweet ending for the character now
another interesting aspect in infinity
war ties in with the notion of sacrifice
and how ultimately it leads to the
Avengers losing Dan ass is willing to
sacrifice his daughter Gamora in the
movie and because of this he gains the
stones this is juxtaposed by Loki and
Doctor Strange both of which characters
are in possession of a stone but they
refused to sacrifice someone's life and
instead hand them over
initially Loki says that he doesn't care
if his brother lives or dies which is
similar to how Doctor Strange says that
if it's a choice between Tony Peter
Parker or the stone that he will always
choose the latter however both end up
caving in when Thanos calls their bluff
and even the way that they hand over the
stones is meant to mirror one another to
show that they're not willing to make a
tough choice similarly the Avengers
first win and their first loss are both
shot in similar ways showing the moments
in how they parallel one another in
Avengers we can see that as Tony lies on
the ground the heroes crowd around him
this is supposed to be a happy moment in
which they breathe a sigh of relief and
finally get the victory that they've
been fighting for the entire film
however in infinity war it's put in
place to show the opposite and vision
lies there dead on the ground whilst the
ashes of their friends surround them
it's a really poetic way to show the
difference between a win and a loss and
it works brilliantly in my opinion the
infinity saga is full of characters that
repeat the arcs of others and nowhere is
this see
more than a nebula and Loki both just
wanted a sibling and a partner but they
were left feeling ostracized because of
their opposites more competitive nature
they even share similar lines of
dialogue in which they say that they
want to get off a planet just wanted a
brother or sister and they have pretty
much lived in the shadow of Gamora and
Thor respectively
I love Loki in general and there's an
amazing moment in both the first door
and Ragnarok where he and his brother
share a moment together in which they
realize how much they mean to one
another side by side the echoing of
these shots across their trilogy really
shows how much the entire three movie
arc centers around the pair's
relationship and it's great to see Loki
changing over the course of the movies
just like how nebula does whilst we
haven't seen guardians vol 3 yet I
guarantee that they will do something
similar with Neb so definitely keep your
eyes peeled for that now these aren't
the only characters that follow a
similar sort of arc to someone else and
peter is of course walking in the shoes
of tony and becoming one of the world's
best defenders now this is quite an
obvious one but it is worth bringing up
to show their similarities the first
real sound that we hear in the MCU is
the song back and black by ac/dc and
this is used as a way to introduce Tony
Stark
it's sort of becomes his anthem and it
purposely reappears and far from home
when Peter is building his new suit now
side by side these scenes gain a lot
more weight to them as we see just how
similar the pair are with one another
and the way that they create and build
things I love the holographic on that
appears in far from home and it really
hammers home the idea that Peter is
going to become the Next Iron Man and
he's finally accepted his role as one of
Earth's Mightiest Heroes now jumping
across to the Winter Soldier we can also
see how similar Bucky and cap really are
throughout the movie we learn that Hydra
are in fact a part of shield and when
you think about it Bucky and Steve
pretty much work in different
departments in the same building
now the iconography of the pair is laced
throughout both the Winter Soldier and
the First Avenger and it's definitely
worth discussing both share a moment in
which they salute and though this is a
common Army practice it's purposely shot
in a similar manner to showcase the
commonality between the two this is
carried across to when we get the first
reveal of the pair and both the angle of
the camera
their positioning and the way that we
approached them is similar but one is
meant to show Steve in a place where
he's managed to get through the pain
where as Bucky is constantly being
subjected to it both fly a jet at one
point and both visit the Captain America
Museum wearing similar clothing and
trying to keep incognito it really
hammers home the idea that they are
pretty much opposite sides of the same
coin while Steve would go on to work for
shield
Bucky would go on to work for Hydra and
these two super soldiers eventually met
in the middle after parting ways with
the people that pretty much controlled
them there's also a brilliant shot when
Steve goes to Wakanda for the first time
that is repeated for his return visit
and when you look at these you realize
how much of a journey the character has
gone on and how much it's changed him I
love these moments and it's things like
this that make the MCU really stand out
and finally is the similarities between
Steve and Tony sacrifice at one point in
the infinity saga both characters have
to lay down their lives in order to stop
a bomb for Steve it's whilst flying the
hydroplane and by Tony it's flying in
Nuka of New York and into space in order
to destroy the Chitauri in these moments
they both reflect on the ones that they
love and an image of them is shown on
the screen
but Steve it's his picture of Peggy
whereas for Tony it's as he tries to
call pepper but both holders say meaning
the way that they put their lives on the
line is shot to convey just how much
their sacrifice will mean and it's a
really hard panting moment now while
Tony survived Steve didn't and it would
be a long long time before he finally
got to get that dance with Peggy in the
end both got to spend time with their
loved ones
I love how similar these moments truly
are and how they ultimately pay off in
the same way and obviously I'd love to
know which ones on the list are your
favorites and if you have any that
should have made it then make sure you
comment below and let me know if you
enjoy this video then please drop a
thumbs up and make sure you check out
our breakdown of the entire MCU Infinity
saga scene-by-scene which is going to be
linked at the end we've gone through
every film and put it all in
chronological order so it's definitely
worth checking out if you want to know
more you want to support the channel
from his letters 99 cents a month then
please click the join button below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early we're gonna come chat us after the
show either follow us at heavy spoilers
or click the disc
link in the description below every
month we give away free movies to people
are subscribe to the channel and this
month he came on the MC u infinity saga
box and all the after D was comment on a
video and make sure you subscribe with
notifications on the more videos he
comment on the more you've a chance of
winning so make sure you get involved
the one is going to be chosen at random
on the 15th of July in this that will be
shipped out from the name to ever gets
the prize it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part Cheers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]